الاحتلال قبل قليل قام باستهداف منزل يعود
لعائله لبد هنا في مشروع بيت لاهيه لا حول
ولا
قو كنا
واقفين صارت ضربه وسيده وبنات
و وبنات عمامه فيديك جووا البلكونه واحده
طارت لجوا
واستشهدت حده طارت لجوا هيك واستش
والثاني طلع ل تحت
الردب وست صامه من
ه هنا طواقم الدفاع المدني ما زالت تحاول
البحث عن عدد من المواطنين تحت ركام هذا
[موسيقى]
المنزل صار قصف من قبل طارات الاحتلال على
هذا المنزل واحنا كنا داخل البيوت قاعدين
في امان الله ما في عننا اي مقاومه ما في
عنا اي سلاح اننا احنا مدنيين جماعه
سلميين تم استهدافنا من قبل الاحتلال
الصهيوني بشكل مباشر دون سابق انظاره
وتحضير وانا احد الناجين الذين اخرجوني من
تحت الانقاد بعد استهداف هذا المنزل من
قبل طائرات الاحتلال الناس تظل يعني
بهدلونا بهدله مش طبيعيه يعني احنا جماعه
سلميين وهي زي ما انت شايف الحجه وزي ما
انت شايف الناس كله تبهدل من تحت مين من
راس الاحتلال الصهيوني يعني فيش تدخل
لاي لاي حد يوقف هذا
العدوان لازالت وتستمر اسرائيل في قصف
وقتل المدنيين يوميا امام مراه ومسمع
العالم اجمع احنا ه الناس امنين كل اللي
ساكنين هنا اغلبهم نساء فيش يمكن ع ازدا
بجوش اكثر من 200 امراه وطفل سكان هذا
الحي الصغير لجوا لبيوتهم لانه م لهم ملجا
غيره في النهايه قبل ع 10 ايام انا اتصابت
قبل 10 ايام فك مكسور مش لاقي علاج اتصابت
في قصف مربع جنبنا هنا قتلوا في فوق 30
شخص واليوم بنفا كمان واحنا امنين في
بيوتنا المتواضعه لا اكل ولا شرب عنا كمان
قصفوا منزل جيراننا جيراننا الامنين
الغلابه قتلوا طفله شو ذنبها هذ الطفله
ايش ذنبها انا هي بس فلسطينيه بتحمل جنسيه
فلسطين ايش ذنبها اخذوا بيوتنا و شردونا
منها اعتقلنا طلعونا عراء في الشوارع ادنا
معتقلين لحتى اللحظه ونسونا بنجري على
عليهن انا بعي اسره فيها يمكن حوالي 12 ست
12 بنت انا بعيل لها اخوي حبسوه دشر مرته
عندي وين اروح انا ايش اسوي ايش نعمل
حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل اذا هكذا هو المشهد هنا كما سمعنا
صرخات الاهالي نتيجه هذا القصف المستمر
والعنيف على المنازل وتدمير المنازل على
رؤوس ساكنيها وايضا ترحيل الاهالي من مكان
لاخر الاحتلال لم ي القصف نهائيا مازال
مستمر بغارات على المواطنين هنا في شمال
قطاع غزه وكان اخرها هنا استهداف منزل
يعود لعائله لبد في مشروع بيت لاهيه مما
ادى لاستشهاد طفله ووجود عدد من الاصابات
انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه